- Hey guys, what's up?
My name is Curly Velasquez.
- And I'm Christian Zamora.
- And we're here at the AMA's red carpet.
As you know, J.Lo's
hosting the AMAs this year,
so we're gonna make celebrities
take a which J.Lo song
are you quiz made by,
- Me!
(pop music)
Are you willing to take it?
- I am so willing to take it.
- Alright. We gotta unlock it.
Don't remember that password.
- Oh, I wasn't.
- [Meghan] Choose a
stunning red carpet look.
Oh my god, I was talking
about this one today!
But I like this one.
- Oh wow. How could I choose?
- This hair is really cool.
Yep. I'm gonna do that.
- Yes!
- This.
- That was mine.
That's the one I chose too.
- [Rebecca] Choose a J.Lo flick.
Oh "The Wedding Planner!"
It's so good!
- It's okay movie.
- Wait, no actually "Maid in Manhattan."
- That one was really
scary, "Boy Next Door."
- Did you guys see the "Boy Next Door?"
- [Christian] I did.
- [Curly] I didn't watch it, actually.
- It is life changing.
- I was just worried that
I was gonna be triggered
the whole time, because he was so hot.
[Curly] ♫ America the bold♫
- [Kira] Choose a J.Lo flick.
- "The Wedding Planner."
- This is hard. "Selena."
- Selena forever.
- [Jack] Choose a J.Lo ex.
- [Jack] Marc Anthony.
- [Christian] I picked Puffy.
No don't pick that one!
Just kidding. Pick whatever you want.
- I choose J.Lo.
- My favorite's Puffy, but you
don't have to choose Puffy.
- Not at all.
- Marc.
- Everyone's choosing Marc.
- He's the sexier.
- I just choose J.Lo.
Is that okay, or do I have
to pick one of her exes?
- [Christian] Yes! Do it!
- [Curly] That's what I did!
- [Nick] And I got "get it right."
- [Curly] (sings) Awesome.
- There's no "it" but you got "get right."
- Oh get right, sorry.
- It's close. It's fine.
- Oh booty!
(hoots)
I should go to the gym
and work on the booty.
- I got Jenny from the block!
(hoots)
- Used to have a little,
now Rebecca Black has a lot.
- Yes girl.
- [Maiah] I'm Maiah from the block.
- [Curly] Ghetto.
- I got booty!
Booty!
- [Christian] That is so fitting!
- That is so fitting!
- I don't have a booty,
I have an extended back with a hole on it.
- I've only known you
for like two minutes,
but I'd say you're Jenny from the block.
- I'm Franny from the block.
There you go.
- There you go! Make it your own.
(pop music)
- It's here! It's here.
- [All] It's here!
- Get it!
- There!
- I think they got it. Get it!
- Yeah. You get it.
- It's here.